(light piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(light electronic music)
- So I have something
that predates the stone.
These are palm nuts.
Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
I'm pleased to be here to speak
to you at this CARTA event,
and I thank Dr. White and Dr.
Churchland for the invitation.
Like you,
I'm passionately interested
in the human mind
and human behavior,
and my particular interests are in
what humans share with other species
and how they are different.
Understanding humans as
members of the natural world
is critical to understanding
human origins and our future.
Let's start with how
humans use hand tools.
Now, humans use hand tools like these now.
And how our ancestors used
them in the deep past.
We can see some continuities.
We can use chopper cores too,
even though we might not
be able to manufacture
a chopper core like this
one without practice.
What about nonhuman primates?
Jane Goodall gave compelling reports
of wild chimpanzees fishing
for termites with grass stems.
Prompting Louis Leakey's famous quote,
"Now we must redefine tool, redefine man,
"or accept chimpanzees as humans."
But the idea that scientists
in the mid-20th century
were unaware of nonhuman primates
naturally using tools is inaccurate.
Darwin, citing a report
published more than 100 years
before Jane Goodall's report,
mentioned wild chimpanzees
cracking nuts with stones
in his book The Descent of Man.
Goodall's discovery should
not have come as a surprise,
even if earlier reports of
chimpanzees cracking nuts
with stones had been forgotten.
Because psychologists
had studied chimpanzees
and capuchin monkeys spontaneously
using objects as tools
in captive settings for decades.
Wolfgang Kohler and Yerkes
studied captive apes,
and Heinrich Kluver
studied capuchin monkeys.
Studies with captive
nonhuman primates using tools
have continued since then,
and we've learned much from them.
I'm going to focus, however,
on what we know about
nonhuman primates' behavior
in natural settings,
in keeping with the
situations of human ancestors.
And contemporary humans,
whose behavior and brains
we're hoping to understand.
I'm going to focus on those
species that have been found
to use hand tools regularly
in their daily lives,
as humans did and do.
So what can we learn from
nonhuman primates' use of hand tools
that helps us understand human origins
and our contemporary minds and behavior?
First we can learn what is shared.
And we can deduce what is not shared,
and then we can work to
explain the differences.
So let's start with the forms of tooling
that we find in nonhuman primates.
And I use the word tooling to mean
using an object as a tool.
Four genera of nonhuman primates
regularly use hand tools,
and in each genus,
one species has been most
studied in this regard.
And I'm going to focus on those species.
Two species are apes, two are monkeys,
two are Asian, one African,
one South American.
Thus they come from across the regions
in which nonhuman primates live.
They most frequently use hand
tools to hammer, puncture,
scrape, probe, rake,
and in a few other ways.
In these forms of tooling,
nonhuman primates perform simple actions.
They produce a change in a
substrate or a fixed object
with one object, a stick or a stone.
Here a chimpanzee punctures the soil
to get at an underground termite nest.
A macaque hammers an oyster with stone,
and a capuchin monkey is
scraping the sand away
from a tuber in the ground.
They use a hand tool to
alter one loose object.
To pound a loose gastropod,
in this case by a macaque.
Or a chimpanzee or capuchin
monkey cracking nuts.
They generate novel combinations
of actions with objects,
some of which plausibly could
lead to achieving their goal,
but often they don't.
This young monkey stacked
a nut on a small stone,
on a larger piece of stone,
and then prepared to strike
it with his third stone.
And that didn't work.
They use simple toolkits.
That is, they use two or
more items in a sequence
for different subgoals.
On the left, a chimpanzee
uses a stout branch
to break into a bee's nest.
And then on the right,
she uses a smaller branch
to dip for honey and larvae.
They select and transport materials,
taken as evidence of planning.
That was a capuchin monkey
transporting a stone bipedally
several meters to an anvil.
Here we see, I think I have to
click again, another monkey.
He's selecting a heavier stone,
which in this case is the smaller one.
He taps and handles both stones
before selecting the heavier
stone to carry to the anvil.
This is Elisabetta Visalberghi
narrating in Italian.
The lighter one, although larger,
was too light to be an effective hammer.
We manufactured the stones
for that experiment.
They modify materials and
manufacture tools by subtraction.
Breaking sticks from branches
and twigs from sticks, for example.
Here we see a chimpanzee
fishing for termites
using a stem that she
collected from a plant
like those shown on the left.
Which she then modified by chewing on it
to have a brush tip.
The lower right image shows
how the brush tip helps
to collect the termites.
They use skilled movements
to achieve a good mechanical
effect with the tool.
By skill, I mean achieving the goal
with minimal effort and
maximal effectiveness.
This capuchin monkey can crack nuts
far more skillfully than I
can using the same stone,
and I can tell you I've tried many times.
He does it in three strikes,
and he was cracking a nut like this.
The monkey weighs 3 1/2 kilos.
This is a big stone, or a big
nut for a monkey that size.
They learned to use
stone tools with others
and from artifacts left by others.
In other words, they have
technical traditions.
They learn these skills
over a very lengthy period.
Chimpanzees learn to crack nuts
over about a three-year period,
progressing from actions with one object
to combining objects, and then percussing,
and finally cracking nuts
when they're about three years old.
Burmese macaques learn to harvest oysters
and crack loose gastropods
in a similar timeframe,
with somewhat different
order of appearance
of the elements compared to chimpanzees.
Bearded capuchins similarly
begin handling objects
soon after birth,
but do not begin to place
an object on a surface
and then work on it with another object
until they're around two years old.
And they begin to crack nuts
some months or even years after that.
All in all,
the developmental timelines
are quite similar across these species.
Orangutans may develop their
tool-using skills more slowly,
but we really don't have
good ontogenetic data on this point yet.
These primates, like
humans, forage extractively.
That is,
they collect food that is
hidden in wood or soil,
or protected by tough shells or rinds,
or by thorns or irritating latex,
some way they're defended.
We see on the right a capuchin monkey
extracting a plant underground
storage organ from the soil.
He's not using a tool for that,
he's digging in the sand with his hands.
They use tools to process
abundant, high-quality foods.
Here we see palm nuts eaten by
capuchin monkeys on the left.
Coula nuts, also called African walnuts,
eaten by chimpanzees in the center.
And a diverse array of gastropods
and marine organisms
cracked by the macaques.
These are all abundant foods,
they're nutritious high-quality foods.
They all spend a lot
of time on the ground,
and forage on the ground,
except for orangutans.
And this is an interesting point,
and one that Meulman and van
Schaik have commented on.
And if you're looking for a book about
tool use in nonhuman primates,
this is actually about not just primates,
but it's called Tool Use in Animals,
edited by Sanz, Call, and Boesch.
It's a good book if you're
interested in this topic.
The shared features I have mentioned.
And some others that I list here.
Bimanual actions,
complementary bimanual actions,
modulating movements,
hierarchical organization
of action sequence,
preparatory movements
with a tool before use,
and others that I don't
have time to talk about.
These are all things that reveal
shared perceptual, motor, cognitive,
and social foundations
for tooling in primates.
And yet,
nonhuman primates do not use tools
as shown in these pictures
that are very common actions for humans.
They don't do it spontaneously,
and to my knowledge they don't
do it with training either.
Why not?
They don't seem to be limited
by gross sensory or motor characteristics.
Here we see a drawing of a chimpanzee
delicately and dexterously
handling a plant stem
and holding a rigid stick.
These were drawings taken from video.
Instead, they differ from
humans in more subtle ways.
Humans perceive spatial relations
between objects differently.
For example, from two years of age,
we can align the axes
of objects and surfaces
to each other accurately and easily,
as when you insert a key into a keyhole.
And nonhuman primates do
not, as far as we now know.
Nonhuman primates align points.
They can align a probe to a
hole, that's a point alignment.
But they don't align axes to each other.
So here we see a bar, a cross,
and a kind of tomahawk shape.
And a corresponding cutout in the tray.
And two-year-old children can
put in the bar and the cross,
and three- and four-year-old children
can manage that tomahawk shape.
And nonhuman primates with a lot of effort
can get the bar in,
and they actually can get them all in
if you just give them long enough.
But they don't just pick it up, rotate it,
position it, and place it in.
They do it by smearing the
thing around on the surface,
and eventually they get it in.
It's a very different strategy.
Nonhuman primates move
one object at a time,
managing a few degrees of freedom.
Humans manage two objects concurrently,
and sometimes more, as when knitting.
I think knitting is an
underappreciated skill.
In sum,
humans can coordinate movements
in space more precisely,
especially movements organized
with respect to the
target object or objects,
than nonhuman primates.
Humans can manage a
greater number of relations
between objects concurrently
than nonhuman primates.
Humans also have more
elaborate social cognition,
and this plays out in many ways.
Without teaching, and without
intentional scaffolding,
nonhuman primates learn
their technical skills
less efficiently than do humans.
Turning to the question that
Drs. White and Churchland
asked us to address,
how did the use of tools contribute
to the origins of our species,
brains, and cognition?
I would say as a primatologist
that I want to turn the question around.
I want to know,
what features of ancestral hominids
and their ecological and
their social circumstances
set the stage for humans to expand
into a specialized foraging niche
that increasingly relied on using tools?
My suggestion is that natural selection
for perceptual and behavioral attributes
associated with extractive foraging,
particularly the perception and management
of spatial relations among objects
and the precise control of the movements
of the body-plus-object system,
slowly but eventually
enabled ancestral humans
to expand into a
specialized foraging niche
that relied on using tools.
Humans are obligate tool users.
No nonhuman primate is
an obligate tool user.
In other words,
I suggest that the key evolutionary shifts
that got humans started down this path
were perceptual and action components
associated with handling and
moving objects during foraging.
These shifts enable humans to use tools
far more flexibly than
can nonhuman primates.
Of course other aspects of human biology
that are associated with
tool use were co-evolving.
Including morphology, social cognition,
attentional control, memory
strategies, and so on.
So our next speaker is going to tell us
something more about how these features
played out in human evolution.
I want to take just a few moments,
the remaining time that I have,
to tell you a bit more about
the work that I do in Brazil,
and the monkeys that I think
are so interesting to study.
And I do this work collaboratively
with Patricia Izar and
Elisabetta Visalberghi,
who are shown in that photo.
These monkeys collect palm nuts.
They take them to anvils
and they use stone hammers
to crack them at those anvils.
You've seen a few clips
of what these monkeys do.
This one shows a female
positioning the nut very carefully,
and working on that stone.
And this is completely characteristic.
What she's doing looks,
it's not chaotic or random.
There's actually quite
a bit of method there.
In the end she arrives at the nut
in a very stable position on the anvil,
and then she whacks it,
even though it does
sometimes fly off the anvil.
That's just one of the
hazards of the occupation.
Very slow-motion.
There's really beauty in that action.
I think these monkeys
are Hercules with a tail.
Capuchins have all the characteristics
we associate with tool use in primates.
They're quite terrestrial,
they use bipedal stance occasionally
on the ground to look around,
they transport things bipedally.
They're extractive foragers,
they percuss objects during foraging
even when they're not using tools.
They're tolerant to
young monkeys near them
while they're foraging.
They're generally social cohesive.
Their habitat has features
that make the monkeys' nut-cracking likely
and of use to them.
Nuts and anvil sites are abundant,
the hammer stones are not.
Those are the restricted resources.
The nuts and the larvae
that they often contain
are both preferred and nutritious.
And they're available all year long.
So it makes a lot of sense
if you're a capuchin
monkey living in this area
to crack nuts.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
(soft electronic music)